welcome everybody uh I'm Maurice Samuels
the director of the Yale program for the
study of anti-Semitism and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you today to this
talk by Richard hurwitz Richard is a
writer investor and the publisher of the
Octavian report a quarterly magazine
devoted to politics economics and
culture his writing has appeared in the
New York Times the financial times the
Wall Street Journal the times of London
uh the Jerusalem Post and many other
Publications his new book in The Garden
of the righteous the heroes who risked
their lives to save Jews during the
Holocaust was published just last week
by Harper Collins and has received a lot
of attention the kirkus starred review
calls it a fresh and grossing
contribution to the literature of the
Holocaust focusing on heroics rather
than despair
Richard received his ba in history from
Yale in 1995 magna laude and was
elected to Phi beti Kappa he earned his
JD from Columbia Law School where he was
a Harlan Fisk Stone scholar he lives in
New York City with his family and his
son Asher is currently a first year at
Yale in Berkeley College
um so here's how it's going to work
today Richard will speak for about 30 or
40 minutes then we'll open it up to
questions please submit your questions
to me using the Q a function at the
bottom of your screen you can submit the
questions at any time during the lecture
and I'll ask them to Richard during the
Q a period we can't actually see or hear
you so that's the only way to
communicate with us and we'll wrap up at
6 00 PM so now I will hand it over to
Richard
thank you well thank you Maury thank you
Vanessa and it's a um a really great
pleasure and very special to be here
um Yale is a very very uh special place
for me an important part of my life
um and as I'll talk in a moment kind of
where this book started and it remains a
special part of my life
um and uh hopefully I'll be up there
later in the in the in the semester as
Maury mentioned I have a personal reason
for being there which is my son just
just started and is doing
far more interesting things than that
than I ever did there but um but uh
anyway thank you all for for joining
um this this conversation and I'm a big
admirer of more of your work and the
Yale program for the study of
anti-Semitism which I believe is the
only only
um such program in the United States so
it's really important work that that's
being done there um so let me see uh
there okay so um on on the this is the
origin of the book um on the left is
something you'll all recognize which is
uh which is um uh Sterling
um and on the right is the Holocaust
Museum I put these images up because
the Holocaust Museum on the Mall opened
uh its doors when I was at Yale and my
family has been in this country for many
generations so predating the Holocaust
um although my my wife's family
um my mother-in-law actually is a
holocaust Survivor
um but we like a lot of American Jews
made the pilgrimage down to the to the
museum on the right and anybody who's
ever been through the museum uh knows
that it's an extraordinarily difficult
innervating experience
um intentionally so the artifacts are
very difficult to see
um the uh um I remember and as I've been
discussing the book with a lot of people
this is something that seems to have a
huge impact on anyone who sees it which
is this this pile of shoes that is there
from from
um you know victims of the showa many of
them when you look closely are in
children sizes so we always have to
remember that of the Six Million who
died one and a half million were
children and um anyway for me
um it was an extraordinarily almost
overwhelming very upsetting experience
and I came out into a room that was
there that was dedicated to the very
small number of people who tried to do
something to stop the Holocaust to stop
Nazism to stop totalitarianism and I
immediately saw these pictures
um and um particularly the one on the
left
and um this uh young man Alexander
schmorel I for some reason this picture
stuck with me at the time I still
remember seeing it um he was I guess
around the same age I was at the time
um and he was a medical student and he
was part of something called The White
Rose which was a small group of students
that was started by on the right you see
um you see
um actually four other men he's actually
um his face is blocked but
um the girl in the middle is Sophie
Scholl and she was an undergraduate at
the University of Munich her brother on
the left Han Scholl was really the the
founder of the of the uh the the
movement um and uh they were very
idealistic students
um the the shoals came from a very
unusual family their father they're from
the same town as Einstein their father
was an Ardent believer in Liberal
democracy but they were also
um devout
Christians and he just he he believed in
Freedom and told them that you know they
should do whatever they can to to stand
up for other people they were I had the
privilege of meeting her
um her best friend who was Jewish who um
told me you know all about you know the
kind of idealism of the family
um they were also notable um they so
what they started doing was circulating
leaflets uh to other students but also
to just you know they would put them in
and mail them to random people around
around Munich and throughout Germany uh
talking about
um uh that this is not the Germany we
know they quoted Plato they quoted
Aristotle they quoted Chinese
philosophers and they tried to foment a
Uprising against Hitler um this went on
for a year they put graffiti in in
Munich um and schmorel the the guy with
the pipe um he actually is among the
first people to publicize the Holocaust
in the second leaflet he wrote that at
that point 300 000 Jews had been killed
in the most beastial away so so these
these were just like wonderful
um
people young people and um and then
unfortunately one day they were handing
leaflets out in in the university and
they came to the top of a staircase and
Sophie realized that she had a lot of
extra leaflets and she they were um
there was an Atrium and she threw them
in the air they started floating down a
maintenance man who was an Ardent Nazi
saw him locked the door
um they were arrested Hitler personally
sent uh his judge down
um from Berlin they were put on uh on
the trial and um and they were they were
executed
and um when when right before Hans was
executed you know he he shouted out and
it was very famous now Long Live freedom
and uh Sophie when she was um when she
was uh on trial made a comment she said
uh everyone believes what we believe but
everyone is afraid to say it and um
unfortunately that was not the case as
we'll get into uh they were very rare
there are many many schools in Germany
they were very well known in Germany not
so much outside of Germany because
people want to believe you know this is
how everyone behaved but it was very
very rare but to me it was also at that
time a bit of a bomb and an antidote to
the horror of what I had experienced at
the Museum and the story stayed with me
and um you know I was a history major at
Yale and I actually thought about
writing my senior essay about the white
rose but I I realized I didn't know
German um and I I had a great experience
I wrote with Donald Kagan on Alexander
the Great but the story stayed with me
and um I um I ended up writing about it
um a number of years ago so but you know
about five years ago for the New York
Times uh I wrote on the 75th anniversary
of their execution uh like sort of
Memorial and it's telling their story
and saying that we should really honor
them and the response that I had was
just so enormous and um and and so
positive and as you all know the
internet is a very scary place there was
not one negative comment about them so I
started writing up
um stories of the righteous
um and I had the same experience
um with a number of articles I wrote In
The New York Times in the journal and
the LA Times and the daily beasts and so
I started I decided to turn them into a
book
um
the um the thing about it is
um that rescue is a um a very
um
undercovered under uh uh focused on area
for for a variety of reasons um and it's
unusual because people really seem to
respond to stories I mean it's not just
my experience but like there was a movie
called Schindler's List that did pretty
well both critically and and
commercially but um so right after the
war and I I have here um another Yale
image this is a picture of the Milgram
experiments you know after the war
people were very interested in in the
evil that happened they were interested
in why people
um collaborated they were not so
interested in what those small number of
people who who helped
um and there was also a view in the
first generation of survivors you know
many of whom actually were not rescued
and had gone had horrible experiences in
concentration camps that that you not
distort the record by focusing on
something that was was so rare I put us
to stick up here um so Yad vashem in
Jerusalem and their Criterion are very
stringent has recognized order magnitude
27 000 people
um with the the title The Righteous
among the Nations uh which seems like a
large number but that's out of 500
million people that were in Europe at
the time so even if you multiply by 10
it's still a vanishingly small number of
people if you were to fill Madison
Square Garden with a random number of
the 500 million you'd have approximately
one rescuer there so
um unfortunately
um you know people always knew Raul
Wallenberg
um you know and and then after the movie
they know Oscar Schindler but there
there's been very little attention paid
to any of the other Rescuers some people
know the story of Denmark
um and the next generation of survivors
um one of the leaders of which a friend
of mine Abe foxman who was the long time
ahead of the ADL had more of an interest
in in in in focusing on righteousness
and and the righteous among the Nations
program has been part of yadav Hashem
from its founding
um it's one of its core missions uh just
to um pause for a moment of the title of
my book in The Garden of the righteous
is actually a real place in Jerusalem
and the reason
um that what it is is every when someone
is recognized as a righteous they plant
a tree in um in in the in the garden
there which is now almost a forest and
and it's a very powerful experience to
walk through it and uh you know it's a
very it's a very beautiful
um uh sort of and very poetic um place
and and gesture that's that's made um
you know for for me I I think there's
there's a handful of reasons that it's
very important to to actually focus on
on Rescue and that was the purpose of of
the book and I tried to talk about this
in my introduction conclusion
one is out of gratitude because I think
there's uh it's very important that
um you know it's both a Jewish value and
a humanist value to to to say thank you
to people
who did among the greatest acts I think
in the history of humanity truly and
risk their lives often for people they
didn't know sometimes for people they
didn't even like
um and just were unbelievably heroic at
probably the worst moment in in history
and uh one a rabbi who was one of the
founders of the movement to recognize
the righteous also said there's a
historical Injustice that we all know
the names of Himmler and gurring and
Hitler but we don't know the names of
people like Susan Mendes or sugahara and
so it's an attempt to correct that
um I also think there are enormous
lessons that we can learn from why
people did this how they did this
um since the second world war there have
been more than 40 genocides um we're
living through a moment of horrific
um um uh war crimes being committed in
more than one place I mean obviously in
Ukraine you have a million uyghurs in
concentration camps 500 000 people lost
their lives in the Syrian Civil War and
there's also goodness going on right now
and I think we need to learn that and
the lessons also are relevant for our
own Society to try to make it a better
place and certainly to try to avoid uh
anything like the Holocaust or the
second world war from happening again
and then I think there's also it is
important um not just for children but
for for anybody I have the experience I
had that um you know a friend of mine um
kind of called the the righteous a
banister you could hold to learn about
the Holocaust and and so for for many
people you know when you start to talk
about six million Jews dead other you
know hundreds of thousands of other
people killed 50 million people during
the second world war it's very difficult
and so a way of sort of you know
beginning to think about and understand
the Holocaust and combat things like
Holocaust denial is to talk about the
good I mean I remember Mr Rogers after 9
11 they brought him out of retirement
and he was asked how do we talk about
this with the children and he said um we
need to look to the helpers and so so I
think that that is important
um and so that's another another reason
why I think these these stories are are
need to be told and need to be
remembered
um
so
um you know one one question like why
did people do this um so there was some
work done um the the this picture is
another amazing person
um he's in my book he he was the uh
cousin of
the trochmes who were the pastor and his
wife in a town called the shambon I'll
talk about it in a moment but um he was
a teacher
um in his early 30s um he he taught both
um adolescents and um and small children
he was like the equivalent of like the
head of the um the college at Yale
um and and he um he gave it he lost his
life uh because it was a Gestapo Roundup
and he was sent to a concentration camp
and gassed but he he was he wrote home
even after he'd been arrested but before
that that he'd found his calling that
that that helping people helping
children and high children was really
what he was put on this Earth to do so
there was some study done
um there was one um pretty systematic
study that was done by two Holocaust
Survivors a husband and a wife who were
also um uh psychologists um the ulners
they wrote a book called The altruistic
personality and they looked at all
different kinds of reasons uh people
might have done this um it's not
entirely satisfying their their main
conclusion believe it or not was that um
the the only correlation they really
found was with parental discipline so um
people who uh disciplined their children
in a loving rational way who explained
what the child had done wrong where the
punishment was measure it with the with
what they did wrong
um they tended to be more um more
Rescuers as opposed to people who
develop more of an authoritarian
personality because their parents would
fly off the handle and corporal
punishment and all that and and I think
my my um just a few lessons that I've
I've seen from this that I think are can
build on that is that there's no
question that the single most important
um thing that uh made someone into a
rescuer was having a strong parent role
model or to or or both parents or some
other you know figure in their life that
taught them at a very young age
um you know to be tolerant of others um
that bigotry was wrong that bullying was
wrong
um and also they tended to come from
very loving homes where they were valued
and this led to strong self-esteem and
that's very important because another
correlation is that most of The Rescuers
were people who had very strong
um inner compass and were willing to
um listen to themselves when everything
else was kind of falling apart so so one
lesson for sure is the like how people
grow up the home they grow up in has a
huge impact on the people they become
and the values that they that they have
and their ability to their willingness
to speak out educational attainment I
say this supports probably what is
definitely a highly educated audience
completely non-correlated most Rescuers
had a belief in something greater than
themselves the single most common was
religion of All Sorts
um all could have been something like
liberal democracy or non-violence these
were people though when I say religion
of real Faith um they were more they
really internalized the teachings of you
know love thy neighbor as thyself the
parable of the Good Samaritan they were
not people who were interested in the
church for signs of external piety
um people are in Creative professions
um or who were in careers that brought
them into International
um you know a lot of contact with other
people all around the world also tended
to be Rescuers
um and a couple of other things just to
note that are kind of universal they're
almost universally modest over and over
and I've looked at hundreds if not
thousands of these cases they would say
things like I I just did what any normal
person would have done I I was just did
the decent thing and of course that's
not true but that is sincere I don't
think there's false modesty in that and
there's an unusual number of them that
actually suffered for what they did
Oscar Schindler had rocks thrown at him
in Germany after the war
um and reasons for that as and I've
talked to a lot of experts about this
one was you know we can't I mean
anti-Semitism was a very real thing and
it didn't go away just because the Nazis
lost the war
um people also question people for like
bringing potential risk to the community
because it was often Collective
punishment
um for this behind the Iron Curtain
um you also have the phenomenon where a
lot of Rescuers who had often been in
the underground with the Allies were
um were persecuted um there's also
institutional anti-Semitism they are so
that was sort of you know a number of
people who didn't come get any
recognition until after the fall of the
Berlin wall and then I think the single
biggest reason though that people were
um were sort of um uh tormented after
the war was they're inconvenient to
people
um they um they go against the ability
to say
I couldn't have done anything because
they did do something and they they
actually they're as rare as they were
they're they're sort of an object lesson
in in in that and and you know Hitler
had a secretary
after the war
um she was walking by a quote from
Sophie Scholl and she realized that
she'd been the same age as her
um you know during the war and when she
saw that she actually said you know I
actually had no excuse for what I did so
I think The Rescuers people resented
very much what they did because it kind
of put the lie to the idea that that um
that everyone just had to go go along
with it um even if you were you know
against it
um I'll talk about a couple of a few
just just to give you a little um uh
like tidbits from the book um to to
hopefully you'll you'll want to read
read more about it so I'll just talk
about a few different uh Rescuers that I
cover
um so the this gentleman um our series
desuza Mendes
um a a review in the Christian Science
monitor
um by a reviewer that I actually I don't
know but I've been a fan of so I was
happy to see him review it he actually
called him the breakout star of the book
um and when people ask me like who was
your favorite that's a very hard
question but he's among my favorites
he's a very powerful story
um he he's believed to have had the
largest single Rescue by a single
individual during the Holocaust um some
people put the number as as many as 30
000 um people he was an aristocratic uh
uh Aristocrat from Portugal um he was a
twin
um his brother was the successful one he
was became foreign minister Susan Mendes
was one of these um diplomats that was
an amazing Entertainer so there were all
kinds of amazing people always in and
out of his house he had a enormous
family of 15 children
um he was a devout Catholic he believed
he was actually as many Portuguese our
descendant of Jews but like hundreds and
hundreds of years ago earlier and he was
a humanitarian and um he found himself
posted in Bordeaux in June of 1940 as
the consul General and um at that time
as many of you know there was a huge
Exodus um as the Nazis came in invaded
France down from Paris millions and
millions of people were in the like the
worst traffic jam in human history and
the luftwaffa was overheads you know
people literally would see their family
members killed um
by Machine Gun fire and
um they would go door to door once they
got to the South because people wanted
to get the really the only way out was
through Spain and into Portugal and
Beyond which were two neutral countries
and people went door to door to
consulates just looking looking for Visa
you actually need more than one Visa but
you needed an exit visa and everyone
slammed the door including the United
States of America and um Portugal too
had uh Salazar who was the dictator of
Portugal is an enormously complicated
guy
um he was sympathetic at that point to
the fascists but he really didn't want a
refugee crisis because he was terrified
of
um losing neutrality and being pulled
into the war so he told sent out orders
to um all of those diplomats no no
refugees are allowed into into into
Portugal or into Spain and um and
particularly not Jews um
Susan Mendez was in his uh in his
consulate and there were literally
thousands of people outside tens of
thousands of people in the street and he
went out one day and he met a rabbi a
young Rabbi who had come from Antwerp
and he had been posted in Belgium before
and
um the rabbi had a large family and
Susan Mendez was basically sent most of
his children home he just had his two
oldest Sons with him and his nephew and
he said to the rabbi why don't you come
spend the night in the don't sleep on
the street come to the consulate and
they had this like heart-to-heart
conversation and Susan ended said you
know I can't really issue visas but I
think I can you know and he had actually
done it in violation earlier already for
a couple people and he said you know I
could let me give visas to you and your
family and the rabbi said to him I can't
accept your offer I can't leave all of
my people here I can't leave everybody
on the street and and Susan Mendez had
this very dramatic on what he described
later as a nervous breakdown he went
into his bed for two days
he got up and he said I'm going to give
a visa to anyone who wants it
um he said regardless of You Know Who
You Are and um he then issued thousands
of visas each Visa could often
accommodate a family and um among the
people he saved were Salvador Dali the
entire Habsburg family the Rothschilds
um I opened my book with the saving of
the H.A and Marguerite Ray who were the
authors of Curious George who were
literally carrying the manuscript with
them
um and um and then he was um when the
door slammed shut a few weeks later he
was summoned back to Lisbon he was fired
um he uh had his pension basically
dramatically reduced um he went through
his entire life savings
um they were literally burning the
furniture to keep keep warm his wife
died prematurely he died he had a stroke
and then he died between a shirt like a
relatively young age and his life was
ruined um and I put a couple quotes from
here you know he survived at one point
and this was a from he had been from one
of the wealthiest families in Portugal
he was going to the Jewish soup kitchen
and uh one of the a teenager working
there I remembered later he saw him and
he was in his you know diplomatic guard
but it was very threadbare and he said
to him he saw him with his family he
said they had the Jewish part of the
soup kitchen and they had a part for
Portuguese which was nice used to come
to this part and and you're not a refuge
Susan Mendes we're all refugees
and he had this amazing line also where
he said I would rather when he made the
decision to do this knowing that he was
going to be in trouble for it later he
said I would rather stand with me a God
against man than with man against God so
so um so he he is uh he's one of my my
Rescuers um I tell this story um which
is like totally different but I just
found it so fascinating um the circus
and this goes to kind of that creativity
um so so the circus was actually a very
um Multicultural uh industry it's also a
family business so whenever you go to
the circus they tell you you know this
acrobat troupe was like the ninth
generation and you know 100 years ago a
lot of the circuses were Jewish and uh
they also were intermarried with
non-jewish Circus Circus people and
there was a family called the large
family that invented um you know if
you've ever seen someone lean back and
kind of like the juggle a person that
was their famous act and and they were
the highest paid uh uh you could see
that in the poster on the left the
highest paid single paid
um uh attraction they were the star of
the Ringling Brothers and Barnum and
belly circus in New York
and in the 30s the Nazis started to you
know basically persecute the Jewish
circus and then eventually starting to
round them up and Deport them to death
camps
um the girl on the right um in the
picture was an acrobat who was a
teenager and um she was a member of this
family and when the things got very
scary
um she approached these two people uh
Adolf Altov on the left and his wife
Maria who were circus owners and who
meant like many circus owners were
performers and um they uh um uh and his
siblings did something similar but but
they they hid her in the circus and not
only did they hide her she performed in
the circus and then they ended up hiding
her entire family um she fell in love
with a clown and they ended up having
two children during the war so they were
rescuing six people in plain sight and
it was a traveling circus and everywhere
it went they would have to
um be inspected by the gestapo and altaf
would tell these stories about
performing in Russia with dancing bears
and somehow they managed to
um to keep this going throughout the
entire war and and saved um and saved
saved this Jewish Family of
um of of performers
um
very briefly um Greece um you know kind
of an unknown story
um in the sense that people know that 95
of the Jews Greece were killed that was
the worst survival rate in Europe but in
the South
um that was mostly in um Salonika and
Thessaloniki where there was a Sephardic
Community but in the South there was a
third kind of Jew not an Ashkenazi or a
or a Sephardic but romanat um who were
there since Alexander the Great and they
actually had a great much greater
survival rate
um largely because of the church and
Civil Society um the man in the middle
who at one point later became acting
prime minister was the Archbishop of
Athens and the head of the Greek
Orthodox church he is the only member of
a
um a church to a head of a church to
formally protest the Holocaust and on
the right it was the chief of police of
Athens and they led a very large and
very wide ranging
um effort to rest rescue Jews they
issued baptismal certificates they
issued local citizenship papers under
false names
and so the Jews have it was also helpful
that um you know people
it's some somewhat unknown that in often
in wherever the Italians were were the
occupying Force which was in the South
um they didn't do roundups and the
trouble came when the after 1943 when
the Italians surrendered and Germans
came into the north of Italy um that's
when the problem the roundups started
and and so the Jews that had made it to
Athens had a little you know they had a
head start and then these people were
quite heroic um on the left I will point
out um there is a book you may be
familiar with right now that came out
around the same time as as mine by by a
prince um Prince Harry
um
I don't know if you know I I I I've read
excerpts from it um but uh much I to me
much more interesting story is his great
grandmother who's on the left uh who is
Princess Alice um she was Prince
Philip's mother
um so she's King Charles's grandmother
um she was a great granddaughter of
Queen Victoria which made her a relative
of pretty much all royalty in Europe her
cousin was the Kaiser her aunt was the
Zarina and um and she um during the War
uh hid
um a family uh um uh of Jews well a
mother and two of her children the rest
of the brothers had actually made it to
uh to to to freedom and we're fighting
um the Nazis but she hid this family for
several um years in her Palace opposite
the Gestapo
um if they had found her she would have
been executed on the spot she was a
great hero um the story is little known
um even in the crown they didn't really
talk very much about it they made her
out to be a little bit of a like like
crazy she's actually buried in Israel
for for different reasons not because of
this but she's been honored at Yad
bashem and um her I tell her story um in
in the book and I I I hope people find
it at least as interesting as as Harry
um but she was she was a real heroin and
a real a real humanitarian she operated
orphanages throughout the war
um and uh and it was just a great person
um I talked a little about Italy um this
is another fascinating story um Gino
Bartoli on the left was one of the most
famous athletes in in Europe
um at the time and particularly in Italy
he won the Tour de France in 1938
um he was uh and he did when he did that
um you know Sports were extremely
important to Mussolini
um he just liked to show himself as a
great Sportsman um they uh the the world
they'd won the World Cup
um Everybody dedicated their Victory to
uh to to to to
um to to him Bartley refused to do so he
was a devout Catholic um and he did two
things he hid the family you see on the
right in a basement of an apartment that
he owned in Florence and he had some
other people as well and then he was
part of um there's a picture of Assisi
what was called the Assisi Underground
and um he would bike with false identity
papers which were life-saving and
because he was so famous nobody bothered
him and he was also had an excuse to be
biking hundreds of miles
um throughout ital the north of Italy
from Genova to Florence to Rome to a cc
CC was sort of the the center of this
where they were hiding a lot of Jews and
partisans in the in The Cloisters
actually and um so he they think he um
he saved several hundred people um as
part of that of that underground did um
and um he never told anybody other than
his son he didn't want anybody to know
about it and he he said you know
you don't go to something you do and you
don't talk about and he said that you
know in in in life um you win bicycle
races they give you medals and he said
there are other metals that are pinned
to your soul and you you get those in
the next life so so he was I mean just
sort of fascinating story about one of
the most famous athletes in in in
um you know in in Europe at the time um
this is also you know interesting um uh
that I'll I'll go a little bit more more
quickly um on the right is a a a
consultant in tsukahara um that his wife
who was a consulate from Japan that was
posted uh in Lithuania where there are
no Japanese people he was really an
intelligence officer and he was there to
monitor troop movements because the
Japanese were convinced the Russians and
the Germans would go to war with each
other and similar to Susan Mendes he uh
he had a lineup all of a sudden of Jews
outside of his his um his home
um which was also the consulate he ended
up issuing thousands of visas as well
and many Jews gave Many religious Jews
I've had the experience with sugahara of
since I've started talking and writing
about him there are at least six people
I know who are actually that I knew
before who I had no idea were actually
rescued by him so he was another great
diplomats in general had an opportunity
to help very few of them did but um but
but he he was certainly one of them and
again
you know a citizen of the world he was a
fluent in Russian and he was both a
Foreign Service Officer and a uh and and
a spy
um and you can see I mean he worked
18-hour days writing visas like this
which in were almost you know it's like
calligraphy and so his hand I mean he he
there's stories of him like not even be
able to move his hand and he wrote visas
until he was recalled and was still
writing them on the on the platform of
the train station
um this is Arena sendler um uh I'm gonna
go more quickly so we don't conscious of
time but she she was uh 29 years old
social worker four foot eleven she was
part of a network she went in and out of
the war so ghetto
um almost daily she saved 2500 small
children in infants and teenagers and um
and was um arrested tortured she
survived um but
um also kept um once the ghetto was the
ghetto where there was like enormously
inhumane conditions was lit was
destroyed
um she uh then continued to Monitor and
follow these children until the end of
the end of the war and she kept list of
all their names with the hope that maybe
their parents who most of whom perished
would be able to come back with them and
she would bury it under a apple tree in
her friend's backyard
um so just like an amazingly heroic
story was completely unknown until about
10 years ago
um one thing I just wanted to to touch
on is community rescue so some people
many people are familiar with with the
Danes you see on the left the king from
from the King on down there's a
apocryphal story that the king wore a
star of David
um he didn't because the gains would not
permit a star of David to be worn by the
Jews and the Nazis from the day from the
day of the occupation the Danes refused
to any discrimination against the Jews
um it's pretty remarkable of the the
parliament they left the government in
place the the fascist party regularly
got less than two percent of the vote
and so the Jews were left alone for a
while and then
um then finally got up to Hitler who
ordered a Roundup
um a member of the uh German
um government there actually tipped off
the the Danish government and the entire
almost the entire country
um from taxi drivers and and medical
students too I talk about an Olympic
rower
um Road it was kind of like uh Dunkirk
um the almost the entire Jewish
population 7 200 people plus 800 spouses
of to Safety in in Sweden and and they
actually the Nazis caught about 500 who
were sent to raise instead and the
government of Denmark regularly called
to check on them and um they were
eventually released and so only 50
Danish Jews didn't survive the war
um another place that was had it where I
talked about the the young man earlier
this is Le chambal um which was a in the
in the Protestant area of France they
themselves mostly descendants of
huguenots there's a long history of
being a place of Refuge from
from uh persecution they had already
hosted some people from the Spanish
Civil War um it was really a group
effort probably the driving force is the
the couple you see on the left
um the uh Pastor Chuck May and his wife
who was an Italian Aristocrat chocolate
was actually from the north he was from
a wealthy family he'd spent time in New
York he was the tutor to the
Rockefellers
um and then he was sent to this very
poor Village and they saved about 5 000
people 3 500 Jewish children many of
whom were had lost their parents and
were taken out of French internment
camps
um in a network with French relief and
the American Quakers
and it was pretty amazing
um I actually had the opportunity to
talk to um to the little girl on the on
the right um who's who's still around
and who's their their daughter and was
actually a teenager when when this was
going on and what you you can see here
this is a there are many pictures in the
Holocaust Museum and elsewhere is that a
lot of the children that were hidden
here because there were more than one
school and there were they villagers
they really tried to make this a normal
life for them um and even when there
would be you know raids they would send
them to the forest and say oh we're
gonna go pick mushrooms and the children
all felt um very safe there was no
instance of betrayal
um and they most of them talk about I
spoke I've spoken to some of them that
they really felt like they had a very
normal
experience they had as close as you
could get in those circumstances to you
know a normal childhood a lot of them
like viewed it as being in summer camp
and
um and and they were you know it was a
Protestant Village but the Jewish
children were they even had um like a
Hanukkah party and and high holiday
services and and there was no attempt to
convert anybody
um and um there was even a sect there
Darvis who viewed it as um the Jews as
the chosen people and were very honored
to be protecting them but you see that
here again they're the like normal life
I put this in because I know there's
some
um uh experts on Camus he was next door
and within walking distance riding the
plague and uh happy to answer any
questions about it um there were always
rumors he knew talk to me I did a little
bit of research on this and I can say
that there were um they they knew they
had a lot of friends in common and it's
pretty clear that on what was going on
in the schimel had did have an impact on
on the plague
um
talked a little bit about
um the the you know kind of group rescue
uh I'm gonna
um you know just skip through this a
little bit um I wrote an article about
this for the journal
um you know again why did places like
Denmark or Albania the only majority
Muslim country in Europe which had more
Jews at the end of the war than at the
beginning do this and again it was a
number of things that came together
um but the most important thing was they
had no tradition of religious bigotry
um they stood together against the Nazis
and they often had some ethos
um you know whether it was uh religion
basa is a Albanian culture a ethos of
hospitality
um uh that brought them together and and
one thing I would just say
um is that
um Community matters
um there was a Dutch rescuer who which
had a mixed record but it was better
than other places who said you know we
the extreme like the people that were
willing to risk our lives were the tip
of the speed year but what really made a
difference was people willing to our
neighbors look the other way or they
were quietly supportive and and so I I
think that is an extremely important
lesson is is to have a culture that that
doesn't tolerate you know um the bigotry
or even even kind of um where people
stand up and when they see somebody
being mistreated and say something and
where that's not valued I think who and
what we value as a society is is
critical to preventing any anything like
this ever happening again so happy to
kind of you know Circle back to that I
just before we go to q a I just wanted
to do one one Yale thing which is um
many of you may be familiar with with um
Barry and Frye who um was sent to uh he
was sent because of this picture uh
which is the very famous writer Leon
foytwanger who was here behind barbed
wire and Eleanor Roosevelt saw this
picture and it was one of the catalysts
that ended up creating the emergency
rescue committee which is now the IRC
and they sent fry over to try to rescue
with a list
um many of the most famous artists
writers political thinkers in in in
Europe and and he did so over 13 months
before he was expelled kind of with the
at the behest of the state department
um and you know here he is with a bunch
of of the surrealists um and he's in the
middle in a villa
um that he rented outside of Marseille
um and and he was part and so they they
you know what an amazing gift and be
single-handedly because of him you know
the the center of you know art and and
literature and culture moved from Europe
to the United States you can make that
argument
um here he is with Mark Chagall and his
wife looking at a painting and I just
wanted to point out that the the tall
guy in the back is a Yale
um who was instrumental to the rescue
and his name is Hiram Bingham the fourth
so his father was the hiring and the
third from Machu Picchu he was the
governor and senator from Connecticut
he himself with a horrible racist and
anti-semite which makes I think what
Harry did even more remarkable so Harry
was the Yale class of 25 went to Harvard
Law School entered the Foreign Service
and was the vice Consul in Marseille in
1940 when the Nazis invaded and he was
instrumental in helping fry and the
entire group of people around Frye do
what they did because he issued visas
but he also hid people in his home
um he others their stories of him
pulling people out of internment camps
um among he rescued hundreds of people
including Chagall and white Bangor but
Heinrich Mann Andre Breton Max Ernst lip
Schultz Lipschitz
like almost the entire you know um
surrealist group um he also inspected
and wrote up reports on the conditions
in the French interim camps and um he uh
for his efforts was um basically
um
transferred to Portugal and then sent to
Argentina when he started to tell people
in the state department you know there's
a lot of like Nazis and gold flowing
into Argentina they moved into Cuba
which was basically a Backwater at the
time it kind of forced him out of the
Foreign Service and he had a similarly
sad kind of decline although he didn't
he didn't die um you know in early the
way Susan Mendez did but had a sad life
and uh fry actually when he wrote his
book um he uh inscribed the copy to
Bingham uh my partner in the crime of
seeing being human lives
and um fry the fry has been honored um I
actually think his entire group should
be honored um and uh Bingham is um uh
was on a U.S postage stamp and he's
received some other Awards but he's not
been honored by Yad vashem
um and he's not been honored by the
state department uh the the the retired
Colin Powell gave a citation
for the group that's for retired state
department
um uh
um employees but there was a bill
entered into Congress last week to honor
60 diplomats with a gold medal and um
Bingham is on the list he's the only
American but a very um you know
underappreciated figure who just you
know even their their families that
would still to this day light a candle
in his honor uh Jewish families every
year for what what he did and then if
you look at the culture the gift that he
and Fry and the group around them gave
to America is pretty pretty remarkable
so I I couldn't resist but you know
mentioning him because he deserves to be
known and I don't know more you know his
100th anniversary of his graduation is
coming up so so so you know he's you all
should be proud of him
thank you uh thank you so much uh
Richard for that
um really you know great
um talk and and and for the book um I I
really think it's such an important
um it's so important to to
um to remember these people in the way
that you do so it really moving and
interesting so I a lot of questions and
there are a lot of questions from the
audience
um so we don't have that much time so
we'll just try to do as many as we can
um first of all just wondering uh what
kind of how you did your research for
this
um what kind of research went into the
book did you travel around did you
interview people
um was it mostly secondary research no
it was um I mean of course you always do
secondary research but I did a lot of
primary primary research in a lot of
archives
um yadvisham is particularly helpful
because at any time anyone gets the
award there's you know eyewitness
testimony and a lot of documents that go
into it so we did LA I think we must
have done re I say week I had some help
on translation probably 12 different
languages and I also um had the
opportunity to interview a number of
survivors most of whom were children and
then I had a fascinating experience
interviewing a lot of children of
Rescuers or tell us a little bit about
that I assume that no Rescuers uh you
weren't able to talk to any restaurants
no they're they're no um but there was
um there's there were you know
interviews with a lot of them um
actually I owe manuscripts and archives
a uh a thanks because um during covid um
there was a there was a documentary that
was made in all the footages in um at
Yale and they put it up online for me
and actually Bingham with a long
interview and I ended up sending it to I
interviewed three of his children they
had not heard their father's voice since
the 80s and so so they were like
profoundly Touched By by hearing it I
mean they mixed I found it really
interesting because
um the children it's mixed um you know
bingham's children review of him kind of
as a saint pry's son who I spoke to said
his father had a lot of issues which is
I think come out now and he thought he
was bipolar I you know didn't have a
close relationship with him at all he he
was sort of negative I mean even uh the
truck May's daughter she you know who
had these parents that were almost you
know they were very prominent in the
non-violent movement when they knew
Gandhi they knew Martin Luther King they
were heroic she said yeah we were saving
all these Jews and they were they were
good parents but like you know they
never came to our piano recital because
they didn't have time and you know like
things like that and I and you know
people had illegitimate children
um you know and I think
um you know but on the other hand it it
made them seem like real I mean these
weren't people like Mother Teresa who
set out to be righteous with their lives
they found themselves in this situation
and they acted in a certain way and they
had flaws like all of us which I think
is
makes it hopeful yeah exactly I mean
that's it's so important to show that
because if everyone is just a saint you
think oh I can never you know become no
they were they were quite the opposite
they were multi-dimensional complicated
people
um so how do you account for the fact
that um if as you said
um religious belief was one of the
contributing factors that there were so
few actual you know like how do you
account for the Catholic churches you
know
um relative lack of
um participation in Saving Jews yeah I
mean well I think first of all you know
there's a whole debate over the pope
right and the his predecessor was about
to come out with a statement denouncing
anti-Semitism in Germany and he died
um and and so I think part of it was at
at the top I mean the church was not a
monolith so the Bartley Story shows that
you know that at least part of the
church
um and the the main movers there were
the Archbishop of Florence and and
Genova and the bishop of Assisi and a
lot of the you know the clergy really
participated
um but um again I think it has to do
with you know why you belong to a church
or why you you know so so again people
were really into hierarchy or who are
into I mean the way the church act it
was you know similar to the Foreign
Service in a lot of ways you know rural
followers and hierarchy people attracted
to that but people who really
internalize the teachings of whatever
Faith um and again they often got that
from a parent or maybe from the local
priest they grew up with they tended to
be you know uh I mean the people in the
chambon were Protestants and they were
very devout one of the people who was
there said you know they didn't read the
newspaper every day but they knew their
Bible and there was a lot of Bible study
so I think it was a more personal faith
tended to be more correlated with rescue
okay and I'll just encourage people to
submit questions using the Q a function
uh at the bottom of your screen and I'll
take a question from the audience which
is
um did you find examples of
um of Rescuers who cooperated or who
formed networks you know even you know
across Europe
um or was it pretty much like an
individual thing no um it was both so
you had individual people
um like
um uh the altoffs um you you had
um countries like Denmark
um you know arena sendler in Poland for
example was operating she put together a
network of like Jewish friends in the
ghetto and non-jewish friends out of the
ghetto and after a while they merged
with something called zagota which was a
very large
um underground organization set up to
save Jews by two women one of whom was a
liberal Democrat one of whom was an
anti-semite
um but who didn't believe you should
exterminate Jews and that was funded by
the the the Polish government in Exile
and the Allies
um there were people like Bartley who
hid people in his basement by himself
but it also was part of a part of the
Assisi underground so um you know
there were there were there were again
there were a lot of people all over
Europe who were rescuing not a lot but
of The Rescuers who were people who were
hiding people in their homes I mean that
was like the most common fact pattern
but then there were Whenever there was a
large-scale rescue often it was part of
a it would be part of some kind of
organized Network and you know I would
uh someone in the audience
um who I know well pointed out that um
the Yale's fortunoff uh Archive of
Holocaust testimony also has a lot of
testimonies of Rescuers um so not just
of survivors and that's an incredible
resource is that something that you made
use of in your in your research yeah I
mean the video testimony is really
important so I did and then also the
showa project USC show a project I mean
they had a fascinating interview with a
guy who was a counterfeit or for Bartoli
who was Jewish and he talked about you
know so so those are yeah those are very
important
um and unfortunately you know like you
know as we were talking about many many
people are no longer with us so it's
really the only the only way we can keep
it the first obviously first person
testimony is the the most important and
here someone in the audience asked what
I think is you know the question
um which is does
learning about these Rescuers Inspire
other people to do the same
um it seems like that's where you're
kind of heading but do you have any kind
of
um proof of that or is it just a hope
well
it's hard to like I don't have any
example of someone saying I did this
because you know valenberg inspired me
but
I can tell you that the outpouring I've
gotten from like a reaction to articles
I've written or even starting from the
book it would say to me
yes I think most people want to believe
that they would have done this I don't
know how many of us would have I mean
it's one thing to risk your
career or to be inconvenienced it's
another thing to risk your life and then
it's another thing to risk your like
Children's Life which some people in
parts of Europe did and that's very
extreme and I don't think it's very hard
for us to judge but I do think what I
hope
is that the inspiration of these people
would make all of us be more like the
people that helped them that created the
atmosphere that allowed this to happen
because that's where you really need to
have a lot of people but no I do think
people are very inspired by them and I
think you know we're not living through
World War II but there's lots of pain in
the world and there's lots that we can
do and and you can make a difference
just Again by standing up to someone
being bullied or by helping you know
support like you know things going on
overseas that are horrific and speaking
out on that and that's all important
yeah that that's that kind of leads to a
question that I had you know written
down also which is
um you know there's so many atrocities
going on that we hear about all the time
from like you know child labor to police
killings to you know what's going on at
the border
um and you know how do you avoid just
feeling overwhelmed and paralyzed
um you know so you don't have you're not
actually
you know uh you you think these things
are terrible but it's just so
overwhelming and you think like what can
you know one person do so you just do
nothing I mean how do you get past that
do you have any yeah I would say I mean
I think
um you know the the very famous
statement you know he who saves one life
Saves the World right is very profound
in a lot of ways I mean one is that I
mean I've experienced that by meeting
descendants of you know like there's
probably a million people alive because
of actions taken into just the 10
stories in my book today right because
of Just The Descendants but also
anything that you do
makes a difference right so I mean in
Afghanistan I know a lot of people that
were involved with rescuing people and
just getting one person out you know to
that there's a there's a story
um of a friend of mine put in his book
on Afghanistan where you know a little
boy is walking along uh Beach and he
sees all these starfish washed up and
and they're they're they're dying
because they're they need to be in the
water and he picks up one and he and he
and he throws it back in and a older man
comes over to him and says why why did
you do like
like that's not gonna make a difference
and he said what made a difference to
that one so yeah I mean the world is it
is is and we have much more information
about what's going on now on an ongoing
basis but I think again
I've heard you know Aid foxman who's a
friend when he when he spoke at my
daughter's school he said you know like
just again like you know standing
starting by standing up for somebody
like I think you know that anti-bullying
campaign is actually people make fun of
it but it's real so
um you know but but
um you know we we again
um supporting people also who are out
there on the front lines doing something
is really important because you can't
not everybody you can't do everything
all the time nor should we expect
ourselves to do that but we can all have
a big effect on the culture and again I
I would like to see people today who are
doing amazing things much more
celebrated I mean like I'm not saying we
shouldn't
have you know think like sports people
and and like the Grammys is fun but we
should also add into that
just as much acknowledging people who
are you know doing things to help people
in Ukraine or with this earthquake
yesterday or you know other other things
like that we don't do enough of that
that's not who we value as a media and
as a society
okay you know there are so many um other
questions and people had like very
specific things about you know specific
Rescuers and um you know unfortunately
we are out of time I would love to have
um you know been able to ask you all of
these questions but I think it's really
a sign that you know your book is really
you know
um you know resonating with people and
that's and that's great people should
feel free to email me if they have if
they have questions yeah could you say
where how they would reach you
um sure yeah no my emails are hero it's
at octavian.com but you can also find it
um there's a web I have a writing
website which is my name Richard
orowitz.com you can email me they are
I'm on LinkedIn or Twitter okay terrific
thank you and this um uh presentation
will be uh was recorded and it'll be
posted on the uh ypsa yipsa
um website soon so if uh people you know
missed it you know please feel free to
direct them to our website and also um I
really encourage everybody to make sure
that you're on the ipsum mailing list
um because we do a lot of uh programs
like this and you know it would be great
to see you at future events which we
have a you know several more uh this
semester which are really interesting so
please join me uh in thanking Richard uh
for this really great presentation
unfortunately you can't see everyone
clapping for you but I will uh morning
thank you thank you for having me and
it's I can't it's just a very meaningful
to to to have a conversation at Yale for
me so thank you for hosting me terrific
and thank you to all of you for coming
bye